This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Superstriresation solenoid switch on. Confirmed. Connect. Coolant hose. Coolant. Pump on. Confirmed. We're going to wait and confirm after suit up. These guys are about to test a space suit. But this is not a recording of an SLAP. This is Cameron Smith's ground floor studio apartment in Portland, Oregon.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。增压电磁阀开启。确认。连接。冷却软管。冷却液。泵开启。确认。我们要在穿好宇航服后等待并确认。这些人正准备测试一套宇航服。但这并不是SLAP的录音。这是卡梅隆·史密斯在俄勒冈州波特兰市的一间底层单间公寓。
That's Julie Sabatier, also from Portland, Oregon. She's a creator of the Public Radio Program and podcasts called Destination DIY. Do we have to say what DIY stands for? Sure, it stands for Do It Yourself. You might think Build Your Own Space View at home is a little extreme on the DIY spectrum. And if you do, I totally agree with you.
那是朱莉·萨巴蒂尔，同样来自俄勒冈州波特兰市。她是公共广播节目和播客《目的地DIY》的创作者。我们必须解释DIY代表什么吗？当然，它代表“自己动手”（Do It Yourself）。你可能会觉得在家自制宇航服在DIY领域里有点极端。如果你这么想，我完全同意你的看法。
It is pretty crazy. We've talked about a lot of kinds of Do It Yourself projects on the DIY spectrum. And if you do, I totally agree with you. It is pretty crazy. We've talked about a lot of kinds of do-it-yourself projects on destination DIY. We have a very broad definition of do-it-yourself. From being your unlawyer to DIY funerals, way beyond the crafts and home improvement projects that might first spring to mine when you hear the words do-it-yourself.
这确实很疯狂。我们在《目的地DIY》中讨论过各种各样的“自己动手”项目。如果你这么想，我完全同意你的看法。这确实很疯狂。我们对“自己动手”的定义非常广泛。从成为自己的律师到DIY葬礼，远不止你听到“自己动手”这几个字时首先想到的工艺品和家居装修项目。
And this is definitely up there with perhaps the most daunting of DIY projects that you could imagine. Sure, there are commercial companies like Virgin Galactic and X-Core creating their own space gear, and they are DIY in the sense that they aren't NASA. But Cameron Smith is hand-crafting his space suit. Under the suit I wear a pair of long johns. I sewed some socks onto them so that they don't slip up
这绝对算得上是你所能想象到的最艰巨的DIY项目之一。当然，像维珍银河和X-Core这样的商业公司正在制造他们自己的太空装备，从他们不是NASA的意义上来说，他们也是DIY。但卡梅隆·史密斯是在手工制作他的宇航服。在宇航服下面，我穿了一条长内裤。我缝了一些袜子在上面，这样当我把腿伸进压力服时，它们就不会往上滑了。
on my legs when I push my legs into the pressure suit. And I sewed, I think I have about 25 feet now of plastic hose that's sewn into the suit and ice water circulates through there and it keeps me cool. And that's absolutely critical. It gets so hot in the suit that you would pass out. I once had a temperature in there,
在我的腿上。我还缝了大约25英尺长的塑料软管，缝在宇航服里，冰水在里面循环，这能让我保持凉爽。这绝对是至关重要的。宇航服里太热了，你会晕倒的。我曾经在里面测过一次温度，
I think of 117 degrees, but it's really crude. You should see it, you know, I don't have a sewing machine, so I just sit on my bed and I watch, you know, the movie or something and just do it by hand. He's not kidding. The sewing looks like something out of Frankenstein. The second layer of the suit is called the pressure bladder. It's basically forming a bubble around Cameron's body
我想是117华氏度（约47摄氏度），但这真的很简陋。你应该看看它，你知道，我没有缝纫机，所以我只是坐在床上，看着电影什么的，然后手工缝制。他没开玩笑。缝线看起来就像弗兰肯斯坦的作品。宇航服的第二层被称为压力囊。它基本上是在卡梅隆的身体周围形成一个气泡，
to hold the air in. The third layer goes over that, and that's the pressure restraint layer. And that's made of panels of non-elastic mesh. It looks like a cargo bag sort of. So those are sewed over the pressure bladder. Because if you were to blow up just the pressure bladder, the suit that contains the gas,
用来保持空气。第三层覆盖在上面，那是压力限制层。它由非弹性网格面板制成。看起来有点像货运袋。所以这些是缝在压力囊上的。因为如果你只给压力囊充气，也就是容纳气体的宇航服，
it blows up into sort of like the Michelin man. And you could survive, but you couldn't do anything. You couldn't bend your arms. You would be in kind of a spread-eggled position just sort of floating there. You couldn't do anything. You couldn't bend your arms, you would be in kind of a spread-eagle position just sort of floating there. You couldn't do anything. Total cost of Cameron Smith's space suit, 2,000 bucks. Around 100 of 1% of the cost of the latest NASA space suit. This technology over the last 40 odd years has become much cheaper, much more available and better. You can essentially build, do it yourself space program today and now luckily I'm part of that.
它会膨胀得像米其林轮胎人一样。你虽然能活下来，但什么也做不了。你无法弯曲手臂。你会以一种大字型的姿势漂浮在那里。你什么也做不了。你无法弯曲手臂，你会以一种大字型的姿势漂浮在那里。你什么也做不了。卡梅隆·史密斯宇航服的总成本是2000美元。大约是最新NASA宇航服成本的万分之一。在过去40多年里，这项技术变得便宜得多，更容易获得，也更好。你今天基本上可以建立一个“自己动手”的太空计划，幸运的是，我现在就是其中的一员。
Cameron is not an astronaut, he's not even an engineer, he's actually an archaeologist, he's on faculty in the anthropology department at Portland State University. But Cameron is an explorer by nature, he's been diving in Puget Sound, survived Arctic winters in Iceland and Alaska, and summited Oregon's Mount Hood more times than he can count. The space suit is his latest and most ambitious project. Showing that it's possible to do it cheaply is, I guess, my part of this larger movement of opening space up to many rather than few.
卡梅隆不是宇航员，甚至不是工程师，他实际上是一位考古学家，是波特兰州立大学人类学系的教员。但卡梅隆天生就是个探险家，他在普吉特海湾潜过水，在冰岛和阿拉斯加度过了北极的冬天，登上俄勒冈州胡德山的次数多到数不清。这套宇航服是他最新、最雄心勃勃的项目。证明低成本实现它是可能的，我想，这就是我推动让太空向更多人而非少数人开放这一更大运动的一部分。
The space suit has been three years in the making. You only have to look around Cameron's tiny apartment to see how committed he is to this project. Instead of hanging art on the wall, Cameron has each of the suit's three layers hanging side by side next to his bed, which is surrounded by bookshelves cramped full of NASA patents and other research materials. His living room serves as the staging area for the gas canisters and the gondola where he tests the suit. Eventually, he wants to connect
这套宇航服历时三年制作完成。你只需要环顾卡梅隆狭小的公寓，就能看出他为这个项目投入了多少心血。卡梅隆没有在墙上挂艺术品，而是把宇航服的三层结构并排挂在床边，床周围堆满了挤满NASA专利和其他研究资料的书架。他的客厅是存放气罐和测试宇航服的吊舱的准备区。最终，他想把
that gondola and all of the life support gear to a balloon that will take him 50,000 feet in the air. He is also sewing the balloon himself. At 50,000 feet above the surface of the earth, camera will experience space-like conditions. And that means he'll need his suit to protect him from extreme temperatures and decompression sickness. And that's what you get from going from sea level to high altitude, less pressure, and you decompress your body starts to swell up.
那个吊舱和所有的生命维持装备连接到一个气球上，带他升到5万英尺的高空。他也在自己缝制那个气球。在地球表面上方5万英尺处，卡梅隆将体验到类似太空的环境。这意味着他需要宇航服来保护他免受极端温度和减压病的影响。这就是从海平面上升到高空所带来的后果，压力降低，你的身体开始膨胀。
Nitrogen bubbles in your tissues start to come out of solution and they give you the bends. It's just what divers get, decompression sickness. A suit with even three pounds of pressure per square inch can keep a person healthy at high altitude conditions. And that's just about what Cameron suit holds on a good day. He's worked hard to try to close off all the leaks, but it's an ongoing process.
组织中的氮气泡开始从溶液中析出，导致你患上减压病。这正是潜水员会得的病，减压病。一套每平方英寸压力仅为3磅的宇航服就能让人在高空环境下保持健康。这差不多就是卡梅隆的宇航服在状态良好时所能保持的压力。他努力尝试堵住所有的泄漏点，但这仍是一个持续的过程。
And Cameron knows what you think of this. I really didn't want people to think I was crazy. And I was really worried about that because, you know, when you say, oh, a balloon and an open gondola underneath that the first thing people think about is they say, hey, do you remember that guy who went up in a balloon in a lawn chair, right? A lawn chair Larry? Crazy dude.
卡梅隆知道你是怎么想的。我真的不想让人们觉得我疯了。我真的很担心这一点，因为你知道，当你提到“哦，一个气球，下面挂着一个敞开的吊舱”，人们想到的第一件事就是：“嘿，你还记得那个坐着草坪椅升上天空的家伙吗？”那个“草坪椅拉里”？疯子。
That's exactly what people think. But not everyone. Cameron has attracted a small team of student volunteers That's exactly what people think. But not everyone. Cameron has attracted a small team of student volunteers who are committed to making the technology of space travel more accessible. In the spring of 2013, they started doing weekly tests. Shipbox, BG levers, one, two, and three open. BG levers, one, 2, and 3 are open.
这正是人们所想的。但并非所有人。卡梅隆吸引了一小群学生志愿者，他们致力于让太空旅行技术变得更加普及。2013年春天，他们开始进行每周测试。气箱，BG杠杆，一、二、三打开。BG杠杆一、二、三已打开。
They check off items on an exhaustive list, making sure the breathing gas, pressure gas, and suit coolant are all in place. The most expensive part of the suit and the only part of the suit that Cameron didn't build himself is the Soviet Air Force helmet he bought on eBay. The helmet is an exception to my general rule of, you know, I want to build it from things that you can easily access or basically not use things from the production system, typically military production systems, that have already sorted out all the problems. I didn't want to do that. I want to solve the problems myself. Why? I mean, why reinvent the wheel? These problems have presumably been solved by other
他们在一份详尽的清单上逐项核对，确保呼吸气体、压力气体和宇航服冷却系统都已就位。宇航服中最昂贵的部分，也是卡梅隆唯一没有自己制造的部分，是他从eBay上买来的苏联空军头盔。这个头盔是我一般原则的一个例外，你知道，我想用容易获取的东西来制造它，或者基本上不使用那些已经解决了所有问题的生产系统，通常是军事生产系统。我不想那样做。我想自己解决问题。为什么？我的意思是，为什么要重新发明轮子？这些问题大概已经被其他人
people, obviously, because people have been in space before. That's a great question. Why reinvent the wheel? Why redo the... It is an incredible thrill for me personally to beat my head against a problem and I can't figure it out and then one day I'm walking home or I'm on the street car and it's a Eureka moment. And it's so thrilling. I got it and I have to almost run home and build the thing and see if it works. So for me, you know, it's an intellectual adventure. It's, oh my gosh, can I figure out the math? Can I mix the gases properly? Can I make this thing hold pressure? Can my mind, can I with my mind, solve these problems? So it's a lot of fun.
解决了，显然，因为以前有人去过太空。这是一个很好的问题。为什么要重新发明轮子？为什么要重做……对我个人来说，撞墙解决一个问题，想不出来，然后有一天我在走路回家或者在电车上时突然灵光一现，这是一种难以置信的快感。这太令人兴奋了。我搞定了，我几乎得跑回家把东西做出来看看它是否有效。所以对我来说，你知道，这是一次智力冒险。哦，天哪，我能算出数学题吗？我能正确混合气体吗？我能让这东西保持压力吗？我的大脑，我能用我的大脑解决这些问题吗？所以这很有趣。
When Cameron puts the suit on, he starts out on the floor. He has to wriggle and shimmy his way into the suit's outer layers. So right now I'll just put my leg up like that and Ben can start getting my foot down. Ben, I blocked the inhale valve on the ONM. You can inhale, but you can't exhale. It's a minor problem, we will fix it. That doesn't sound like a minor problem. What I mean is that the mechanism is so simple that I believe it can be fixed.
当卡梅隆穿上宇航服时，他先从地板上开始。他必须扭动身体钻进宇航服的外层。所以现在我先把腿抬起来，本可以开始帮我把脚放进去。本，我堵住了ONM上的吸气阀。你可以吸气，但不能呼气。这是一个小问题，我们会修复它的。这听起来不像是一个小问题。我的意思是，这个机制非常简单，我相信它是可以修复的。
We just haven't got the solution yet. It turns out Cameron isn't the only one on the metaphorical floor wriggling into his homemade space suit. I could actually start a whole new radio show just about the DIYers who are trying to get themselves into space. There's this Danish company called Copenhagen Suborbidals, and they're building rockets and space capsules in an abandoned shipyard in Denmark. These guys have the goal of suborbital flight in mind, like Ellen Shepherd, they'll just go up and come right back down again rather than orbiting the Earth like John Glenn.
我们只是还没找到解决方案。事实证明，卡梅隆并不是唯一一个在隐喻的地板上扭动着钻进自制宇航服的人。我其实可以专门为那些试图把自己送入太空的DIY爱好者开一档全新的广播节目。有一家丹麦公司叫“哥本哈根亚轨道”，他们正在丹麦的一个废弃造船厂里制造火箭和太空舱。这些人以亚轨道飞行作为目标，就像艾伦·谢泼德一样，他们只是飞上去然后直接回来，而不是像约翰·格伦那样绕地球轨道飞行。
Copenhagen suborbitales and Cameron Smith, the space suit guy, they've actually been working together. Christian Von Bengston is the co-founder of Copenhagen suborbidals, and he's talking to Cameron about building suits for them to use once they're ready to replace their crash test dummy with a live human being. Christian's approach to building his space capsule is right in line with what Cameron is doing with his suit. A lot of the stuff we're buying is, you know, the Danish equivalent to Home Depot. Take, for example, the heat shields. NASA has used some pretty fancy materials like reinforced carbon and high-purity silica fiber
“哥本哈根亚轨道”和宇航服男卡梅隆·史密斯，他们实际上一直在合作。克里斯蒂安·冯·本格斯顿是“哥本哈根亚轨道”的联合创始人，他正在和卡梅隆商讨为他们制造宇航服，以便在他们准备好用真人代替碰撞测试假人时使用。克里斯蒂安制造太空舱的方法与卡梅隆制造宇航服的方法如出一辙。我们购买的很多东西都是丹麦版的“家得宝”。以隔热罩为例。NASA使用了一些非常高级的材料，比如增强碳和高纯度二氧化硅纤维，
to create heat shields for the shuttle and other vehicles. For the space capsule, we have a heat shield made of cork, which is just bought at a local carpet shop. Did you say cork like CORK? Exactly. And a lot of people find it funny that we use cork as a heat shield and it might be a bit funny, but it's a perfect solution for it. What would be the wood-based equivalent of steam punk?
来为航天飞机和其他飞行器制造隔热罩。对于太空舱，我们有一个用软木制成的隔热罩，这只是在当地的地毯店买的。你说的是软木（CORK）吗？没错。很多人觉得我们用软木做隔热罩很滑稽，这可能确实有点好笑，但它是完美的解决方案。蒸汽朋克的木质版本会是什么？
Tree punk, bark punk, wood punk, arbor punk. Arbor punk. I like that one. Anyway, both of these examples, may on the surface, seem as removed as possible from the sleek, polished, and perfectly engineered products of NASA. I mean, their heat shields made out of cork. But they all possess the same problem-solving genius needed to allow humans to exist in
树朋克、树皮朋克、木头朋克、乔木朋克。乔木朋克。我喜欢这个。总之，这两个例子表面上看起来可能与NASA那些光滑、抛光且经过完美设计的航天产品相去甚远。我的意思是，他们的隔热罩是用软木做的。但他们都拥有同样的解决问题的天才，这种天才使得人类能够在
an environment where no human has any business be. One of my favorite scenes in any movie is an Apollo 13. When the ground-based crew realizes that they have to adapt the square carbon dioxide air filters from one part of the ship to fit into the round carbon dioxide scrubber in another part of the ship or all the astronauts will fixate and die. We're about to scrubbers on the command module. They take square cartridges. It's one's on the lemma round. Tell me this isn't a government operation. It's just isn't a contingency we've remotely looked at.
人类本不该存在的地方生存。我最喜欢的电影场景之一是《阿波罗13号》。当地面控制人员意识到他们必须改造飞船一部分的方形二氧化碳空气过滤器，以适应飞船另一部分的圆形二氧化碳洗涤器，否则所有宇航员都会窒息而死。我们正在处理指令舱上的洗涤器。它们用的是方形滤芯。登月舱上的是圆形的。告诉我这不是政府操作。这根本不是我们预想到的突发情况。
Those CO2 levels are going to be getting toxic. Well, I suggest you generally then wait to put a square peg in a round hole. Rapidly. That's the sound of the NASA engineers throwing all the available materials on the spaceship on a table. We gotta find a way to make this fit into the hole for this. Use the nothing but that. Let's get it organized.
那些二氧化碳水平会变得有毒。好吧，我建议你们别再试图把方钉塞进圆孔里了。快点。那是NASA工程师把飞船上所有可用材料扔在桌子上的声音。我们必须找到一种方法让这个东西塞进那个孔里。除了那个什么都别用。让我们把它组织起来。
Okay, let's build the shelter. Let me get some coffee going too. So when I think of Cameron, I think less lawn chair Larry, and more 60s engineers sporting the horn rims and the short sleeve shirt with a tie, he's scattering the parts across the table and attacking the problem. When I have to design something very specific, and I have to look to how other people have done it, if I can't figure it out myself, almost always it's the Russian spacesuits that I'm modeling after.
好吧，我们来建避难所。我也去煮点咖啡。所以当我想到卡梅隆时，我想到的是“草坪椅拉里”，更多的是60年代戴着黑框眼镜、穿着短袖衬衫打领带的工程师，他把零件散落在桌子上，攻克难题。当我必须设计一些非常具体的东西，并且必须参考别人是怎么做的时候，如果我自己想不出来，我几乎总是以俄罗斯宇航服为模型。
They never had as much money. And so they had to do things in a more inventive way. Whether you're in a garage or at a big company or in a gondola if it'd be thousand feet, the design process is the same. Research, express the prototype, test and cycle. But with Cameron's project, the stakes are significantly higher.
他们从来没有那么多钱。所以他们必须以更具创造性的方式做事。无论你是在车库里，还是在大公司，或者是在一万英尺高的吊舱里，设计过程都是一样的。研究、原型制作、测试和循环。但对于卡梅隆的项目，风险要大得多。
It would be so embarrassing to get killed in it, you know. So, I'm going to make it work. Notice that he said embarrassing in that sentence, not terrifying. Which, to me, sounds just like an astronaut. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Julie Sabatia, creator of the Public Radio program and podcast Destination DIY. The show is currently fundraising on Indie Go Go to produce more stories of makers, builders and offbeat creators.
死在里面会很尴尬，你知道的。所以，我要让它成功。注意他在那句话里说的是“尴尬”，而不是“可怕”。这对我来说听起来就像一个宇航员。本周的《99%隐形》由公共广播节目和播客《目的地DIY》的创作者朱莉·萨巴蒂尔制作。该节目目前正在Indie Go Go上筹款，以制作更多关于制造者、建造者和非主流创作者的故事。
If you want to pitch in like I did, you can do a search on Indie Go Go for Destination DIY or go to destination diy.org. One of the rewards packages includes a really great set of zines on how to make radio. I think many of you will enjoy. The program is destination DIY, search for it on Indiegogo. 99% invisible is Sam Green span Avery Troubleman and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. I tweet at Roman Mars, Sam tweets at Sam listens,
如果你想像我一样捐款，你可以在Indie Go Go上搜索“Destination DIY”或者访问destinationdiy.org。奖励套餐之一包括一套非常棒的关于如何制作广播的杂志。我想你们很多人会喜欢的。节目是《目的地DIY》，在Indiegogo上搜索它。《99%隐形》的成员有萨姆·格林斯潘、艾弗里·特鲁布曼和我罗曼·马斯。我们是旧金山91.7本地公共广播电台KALW和旧金山美国建筑师协会的一个项目。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞我们的节目。我在推特上是@RomanMars，萨姆是@SamListens，
Every tweets at Trufflemen, that's the E before the L But right now on our website, we have a couple of really fantastic pictures of Cameron's homemade space suit. It really is a work of art. pictures of camera and homemade space suit. It really is a work of art. Check it out at 99pi.org. Radio tempi. Radio tempi. Radio tempi.
艾弗里是@Trufflemen，那是L之前的E。但现在在我们的网站上，我们有几张卡梅隆自制宇航服的精彩照片。它确实是一件艺术品。卡梅隆自制宇航服的照片。它确实是一件艺术品。去99pi.org看看吧。广播节奏。广播节奏。广播节奏。
Radio tempi. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
广播节奏。这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。